hello everyone and welcome to the
biggest ideas in the universe this is
our second Q&A video
I'm your host Sean Carroll and we'll be
talking about the questions that came in
after the second video in the series the
second idea that we were talking about
namely change which was really about
calculus and I have to say it's been
very heartwarming to see people watch
the videos respond to them even if
they're about you know somewhat abstract
technical topics we have started very
very gently with conservation and change
we're gonna ramp up as the videos go on
but the same idea is the basic
philosophy that it's for everyone
literally everyone can follow these
videos if they wanted to there's no
prerequisites presumed but there's an
interest presumed you have to be willing
to think about it and see where that
goes and so as a treat today we have a
little bit of a technological
improvement watch this that's right we
actually now have a dark background and
light writing on the notepad this was a
request several people made so we're
trying it out let me know how it goes I
will take input on this the one thing
that we need to do to make that happen
was I was using a program called Notes
Plus which with on a MacBook Pro no on
an iPad pro with the Apple pencil here's
my Apple pencil and it works very very
well for note-taking those pluses great
helps uh you can export the PDFs very
easily to your laptop or whatever but of
all the different background options
they were all light-colored there was
only for writing in dart pen on light
backgrounds so this one is called
notability I've switched programs to
notability another great program you can
look it up if you're interested in doing
this and this one has dark backgrounds
now this particular background is sort
of a almost a fabric kind of theme to it
but hopefully we'll just be in the
background and be a dark grayish blue
and that will be good you can do totally
black but that just seemed less
aesthetically pleasing to me okay there
were a large number of questions I'm not
going to get to nearly any of them I'm
gonna make zero effort to specify who
asked
each question sorry about that but you
still get the warm feeling from having
asked to question many of the questions
overlap so I'm sort of grouping them
together in themes and also between you
and me given that I've actually recorded
a couple of the other videos coming up
the videos are getting long I don't want
the videos to be long and want them to
be shorter and accessible so I'm going
to try to keep things a little bit
shorter we could ask questions forever
right I'm gonna try to focus on some of
the best ideas oh yes I forgot to say
that I've improved I think my green
screen technique enough where I do not
necessarily need to wear a red shirt
just to make it work again we'll see
whether that works or not okay on to the
questions what do we have the first
question you know is pretty it's a it's
a basic one how do we get from rate of
change of position over time to the
actual position over time how do we get
from velocity which is rate of change of
position over time to position over time
X of T so and I put this one in there
explicitly because in principle I
answered that one in the video that was
part of what I was trying to do but I'm
extremely well aware that just because I
think I've answered something doesn't
mean that everyone thought it was
perfectly clear the first time so let me
just say a little bit about the
intuition behind here okay the simplest
possible way of thinking about it
imagine that you're in a car and this
car is so good that it can accelerate
from 0 to 60 60 miles an hour for those
of you not in the United States in
literally zero seconds and furthermore
it can brake in literally zero seconds
so if you plotted the velocity versus
time of this car velocity versus time
okay it's zero and then boom 60 miles an
hour and then boom it's zero again right
and furthermore imagine this went on for
you drove for one hour
well pretty clearly you can figure out
how far you went in fact you can figure
out your position as a fun
of time right just from that if I
plotted here is your position X as a
function of time T a little arrow here
then your position is you're not moving
and then you're moving at some constant
velocity for an hour 60 miles an hour
and then you stop moving okay that is
the answer I mean that's just sort of
intuitive we sort of know that that's
what it means to be moving at 60 miles
an hour the point is the slope of this
curve X of T curve is the velocity and
if you think about what it means when we
said derivatives and integrals
derivatives are the slopes of curves
integrals are the area under the curve
so when we say that the derivative of X
is V that kind of looks like it makes
sense over here the slope of the curve
is zero and indeed v-0 over here the
slope of the curves some constant value
that is not zero
and indeed V is some constant value over
here again you're back to the slope
being zero and indeed the velocity is
zero so it does in fact look like you
can go this way V equals DX DT velocity
is the derivative of x over time but
also intuitively looks like you can go
the other way if you really sit and
think about it right the velocity popped
up very very quickly to a constant value
and if you think about it what we're
saying here is that X is the integral of
the velocity that's how you're supposed
to go from the velocity to the position
so when you're the integral is the area
under the curve and when you're in the
position here where you're not moving at
all with the velocity is zero there's no
area under the curve and indeed x equals
zero there you go
once you come to up here and you sort of
divide the area under the curve into
these little regions and you add them up
okay there's a little bit there's
another little bit and they accumulate
over time what you would expect is the
area under the curve goes from zero it
goes up by a little bit a little bit
more a little bit more and
bit more and then it stops going up once
the velocity goes back down to zero
indeed that is exactly what the curve of
velocity of X versus time looks like it
starts going up at a constant rate
because you get more and more area under
this curve and then it stops going up
when the velocity goes back down to zero
so it goes both ways
X is the integral of the velocity times
time over time I should say that's what
it means again the symbols the equations
are not what matter we're not gonna try
to remember them but that is what it
means so this is how you should think of
it whenever you have a physics question
like whenever you don't understand some
concept that the professor thinks that
they've just taught you you should say
well let's simplify it to like the
simplest most straightforward dumbest
example I can think of surely I can
understand that maybe that gives me
enough understanding more generally the
point being of course that in other much
more general situations where the
velocity is not just 0-60 and then zero
it would still be the case that the
velocity is the derivative of X and X is
the integral of the velocity but it
would be harder to go back and forth
mathematically but you could do it okay
wanted to get that out there because
this is like I said it's for everybody
good now now we're getting a little bit
trickier in the questions here Zeno's
paradoxes remember Zeno's paradoxes one
is I'm gonna forget you know he always
had colorful characters like Achilles
and the tortoise or whatever but one is
he claimed that motion was impossible
this is Zeno of Elea this is an ancient
Greek philosopher he says motion is
impossible because look let's say you
want to go in X and by the way
parenthetically once again this is
something that scientists and
mathematicians do all the time I was
just drawing some plots where T was the
horizontal axis and look X was the
vertical axis now I draw a plot where X
is the horizontal axis get used to that
this is part of the game anyway this
isn't really a plot here this is just an
illustration so you want to go from your
starting point at x equals 0 to some
finishing point let's just call it x
equals 1 but z no cleverly says okay
guess what to go from 0 to 1
you have to go halfway there so you have
to reach the point x equals 1/2 and to
go from 1/2 to 1 you have to go half way
in between that so you have to
eventually reach the point x equals 3/4
and then you have to go half way between
that so you have to get 2x equals 7/8
and so forth you can keep going and
smaller and smaller increments and Zino
points out correctly there are therefore
an infinite number of intervals that you
have to pass to go from 0 to 1 therefore
you can't go through an infinite number
of intervals therefore you can't get
there you can't get there from 0 to 1 we
all know this is crazy talk because
we've seen people go from one point to
another motion is in fact possible is it
this what is the resolution to this
apparent paradox and so the question is
this calculus help you understand this I
think in some ways it does I would say
that calculus helps explain what is
actually going on I don't think the
calculus is necessary to explaining this
kind of paradox from the point of view
that we've been talking about here and
the way to think about this is sure you
have to go from 0 to 1/2 from 1/2 to 3/4
from three-quarters or seven-eighths etc
but you don't have to spend equal
amounts of time doing that right I mean
if you moved at a constant velocity you
would spend half the time going from 0
to 1/2 1/4 of the time going from 1/2 to
1/4 1/8 going from 3/4 to 7/8 and so
forth right so the velocity would be the
same even though you have to spend an
infinite if you know you have to pass an
infinite number of intervals you have to
spend less and less time doing them so
not only does the distance that you
Traverse go to zero as you get closer
and closer to your goal but the time it
takes to traverse that distance goes to
zero so overall if you say how much time
will it take you to go from 0 to 1 it's
a finite amount of time you can
formalize this using calculus in fact
the idea of an infinite series is a big
part of calculus a big part of calculus
is saying that some function X can be
written as some function of 0 of X plus
some function f1 of X plus another
function of 2 of X where these functions
become smaller and smaller in the
where you care about so plus dot dot dot
an infinite number of these functions
you have to add up this is part of the
idea of approximating by something that
looks like just an approximation right a
finite little bit but when you take the
limit as some parameter goes to zero
this approximation becomes exact that is
what calculus is all about okay next
question was can you calculate the
derivative of a fractal I'm not going to
write all the questions all the words to
all the questions what about fractals so
fractals are curves that have sort of an
infinite amount of structure in them so
a famous fractal for example draw a
straight line then draw a triangle so
that the one side of the triangle takes
up one-third of the line right so this
is one-third one-third one-third then
draw another triangle other triangles
that have that same property for all the
lines you've drawn and draw other
triangles that have that same property
for all the lines you've drawn and do
that literally an infinite number of
times okay so what you would find is
that this is a curve but it is not a
smooth curve this has some name
someone's snowflake okay
it's not a smooth curve so
mathematicians of course have classified
what that means in wonderful detail no
you cannot take the derivative of a
fractal a fractal is not something that
has a limit to these questions right I
mean there were some grumbles in the in
the questions and I anticipated if you
if you watch carefully the video I said
look the mathematicians are gonna be
outraged the mathematicians were
outraged in the questions that's okay
the point is that we were making some
assumptions and not explaining them not
listing them explicitly one is that the
curves that we're dealing with are
smooth and one feature of that is that
the limit exists to these kinds of
questions you're talking about so if you
look back at this curve we drew a
velocity versus time the limit as you
approach the acceleration point right
the velocity is zero before the
acceleration for
the velocity is 1 or 60 miles an hour
after the acceleration point up here if
you approached the velocity curve if you
approach that point on the velocity
curve from the two different sides you
would get two different answers so the
limit as you approach from two different
sides gives you different responses
there's there's a discontinuity in the
curve technically speaking you could not
differentiate this curve V of T you can
differentiate this curve X of T well you
can't quite differentiate it there
because it's not smooth either but
that's okay we sort of approximate it or
think of it as a step function it's
something that just suddenly changes its
value philosophically this is a
difference between mathematicians and
physicists physicists say okay I know
I'm cheating a little bit but I know
it's gonna work too I'm gonna get on
with my life and solve some physics
problems mathematicians go like no no
cheating is exactly what we're here not
to do we should do better than this and
you need both there's not one way of
doing things that is correct and the
other incorrect they work together but
I'm more on the physics side to my own
approach to these issues okay
here's a tough question why is
integration taking the integral of some
function that someone hands you harder
than differentiation taking the
derivative of some function someone
hands you this is a true fact when you
and someone gives you a function f of X
you could take its derivative DF DX you
could take its integral integral of f of
X DX this is the slope at any one point
this is the area accumulated under the
curve but when you sit down to do that
when you actually go through the math
run through the equations differing
differentiating functions is easy I mean
you can do it because there's very few
functions out there that you cannot just
differentiate and get an exact what we
call an analytic answer to integrating
is really
it is old it is very very often the case
that realistic functions that we have in
physics and math cannot be exactly
integrated that's why you put it on a
computer let the computer do all the
work so this profound philosophical
question is why is that true after all
they are inverses of each other we just
showed that with our simple little
example right the derivative of the
integral is the original function so I
mean technically the answer is I don't
know exactly why I do not have a nice
clever sounding answer for why
differentiation is so much easier than
integration what I will note though is
that it's not at all unusual state of
affairs it is very often the case that
you have two operations two mathematical
operations where doing it one way
there's an inverse you can do it the
other way but they're not equally easy
think about a very different simpler
problem which is just factoring one
number into its prime factors right if
we imagine just to simplify that we're
given a number and that's our number and
someone promises us that it is the
product of two prime numbers a and B so
a is a prime number B is a prime number
and is their product there's two
questions you might ask one is given
just n can you figure out what a and B
are that is a very hard problem that
takes time to work through all the
different possibilities on a computer if
n is really really big this could be an
impractical question to ask
whereas if people give you a and B and
say multiply them it's very easy to
multiply them and get in it doesn't take
any time at all relatively speaking
right a pocket calculator can do it so
they are inverses of each other these
two questions given n what are a and B
given a and B what is n but they're not
anywhere near equally hard so this is a
feature this is a feature of
mathematical problems more generally
that doing it one way and doing it the
other doing a problem doing its inverse
need not be equally hard and in fact
this is the basis of a very famous
problem in complexity theory complexity
theory is the study of how hard problems
are and you can quantify that by
these steps would it take on a computer
to solve a problem algorithmically so
there's a famous battle or comparison
between P versus NP these are two
classes of to complexity classes to
comply mathematical problems P is the
set of problems that are easily solvable
and again I'm not going to go into the
details sorry for the experts in the
audience the details are that if you can
solve the problem in polynomial time
where the polynomial means polynomial
and the size of the problem that you're
giving it then it's in P a polynomial is
can be big numerically the polynomial
functions are grow much more slowly than
let's say exponential functions so this
is classified as fairly easily solvable
NP the solutions if you're given a
solution is easily checkable so from our
example of factoring right given one
number whether its factors versus two
numbers multiply them together to get
the number it would seem clear that P
the set of all problems that are easily
solvable is way smaller than NP the set
of all problems for whose solutions are
easily checkable but when you want to
prove it it turns out to be really
really hard so there's a question on the
market right now is P equal to NP and no
one knows the answer actually everyone
knows the answer the answer is no
they're not thankful but no one has been
able to prove the answer if you prove
this that P and is not equal to NP or if
you prove that it is you will win a
million dollars it's that kind of
problem but the point I want to get is
not to get into complexity classes but
even though I can't give you a simple
nice beautiful clever explanation for
why integration is harder than
differentiation you shouldn't be
surprised by that fact it is a general
feature of mathematical procedures that
even if there's one way of going and
there's an inverse to that they're not
equally easy or equally hard so whether
or not that makes you feel better about
differentiation integration I don't know
but so be it
okay there's another question that came
up a few times so let me get it out
there on the table we talked about F
equals MA force equals mass times
acceleration times acceleration
so which mass are we talking about here
you may have been exposed to various
different concepts that all go by the
name mass there is the inertial mass
that's what this is inertial mass in
classical Newtonian mechanics is just if
I put a force on the object how much
does it accelerate the quotient of those
two things is the inertial mass it's
basically how much do you resist the
acceleration when the force is being
acted upon you that's one thing so
there's inertial mass there's also
gravitational mass systems with mass
both respond to a gravitational field
and cause a gravitational field and the
amount of response and the amount of
cause is proportional to the mass so it
is a fact of physics that the inertial
mass of an object is equal to its
gravitational mass Newton wondered about
this Einstein wondered about this we
have different explanations for it but
it doesn't matter they sort of these are
two concepts that serve different
purposes but they are numerically
exactly equal to each other so whichever
mass you want but then there's something
called the relativistic mass so this
comes from the fact that once relativity
comes on the scene things change when
objects are moving close to the speed of
light right their clocks tick
differently their rulers are different
lengths and so forth and so is it the
relativistic mass that goes there or
just a good old Newtonian inertial mass
so you should be able to guess since
we're doing Newtonian physics not
relativity that it's the inertial mass
it's the nonrelativistic mass that goes
in there but I think that's true but I
wanted to bring this up because most
modern physicists will never even talked
about the relativistic mass what the way
that they used to think about it was
there's a mass you could put something
on a scale okay you could weigh it and
then if you knew the gravitational force
down you could figure out what the mass
of
thing was but then if you moved it close
to the speed of light it would take more
and more oomph to push it at a faster
and faster velocity so it's as if the
mass is increasing these days we would
say that the energy is increasing but
the mass we define to be the rest mass
so personally I would never use the idea
of relativistic mass the the only thing
that we would ever use is the rest mass
M equals the rest mass and when you
write e equals mc-squared
what you're defining is not the total
energy of the system you're defining the
rest energy you're defining the energy
that it would have if it were at rest if
it were not moving that's what equals M
c-squared is telling you so that's what
it is for this but I do want to give you
that even though we have been doing
relativity yet I wanted to warn you like
the definition of mass is not gonna
change it's always the rest mass which
is equal to the inertial mass which is
equal to the gravitational mass okay
here's a good question which is a little
bit philosophical but if it'll get us it
will once again prefigure something that
is going to come later is velocity which
we've been talking about a lot really an
instantaneous quantity that is to say
can we really define it at a moment of
time so what we mean here is you know if
you have some here's T here's X okay and
we say that if you have a curve the
velocity is supposed to be the slope of
this curve right clearly at any one
moment T there is something called X if
this is T not let's say this is exit T
not no one has any problem saying that
exists at that moment the velocity is
the slope the rate of change and there's
sort of a slight tension between two
different claims one is the velocity
exists at each moment of time it does it
certainly exists at every moment of time
we could differentiate this curve take
its derivative and then we would get the
velocity at every moment but the other
is could you really consider the
velocity to be an instantaneous quantity
because if you're saying the velocity is
the slope it's the rate of change which
is it's the rate at which the both the
value of X of T right now compares to
its value in an infinitesimal moment in
the future or in the past so in some
sense you have to know something about
the immediate future or the immediate
past to define what you mean by the
velocity so the answer is that's
everything I just said is perfectly true
in this way of thinking about it where X
as a function of time is the fundamental
thing which by the way is the way that
Isaac Newton would have thought about it
then yes you need a little bit of
information around the moment T naught
to define the velocity in terms of the
position but there are other ways of
doing classical mechanics you know we
sort of move back and forth between
velocity and momentum P equals mass
times velocity because if the mass is
constant and who cares you can use
momentum or velocity there are other
ways of doing classical mechanics which
we will get to a couple of videos from
now where you treat X and P as the
fundamental things position and the
momentum and you treat them as truly
independent you say no matter what X is
P can be anything and and people say
okay
at one moment of time I get that but if
I knew what ex was doing through time
then P can't be independent of it and
the answer is yes it can but this
equation might not hold that is to say
rather than thinking of this equation as
a definition you can think of it as
something that may or may not be true
and then P really has a life of its own
it's really something other than just
being derived from the mass and the
velocity but we aren't there yet so for
the purposes that we have right now X as
a function of time really is fundamental
you figure out what velocity is but I'm
just letting you know ahead of time it's
not the only way to go it's not the only
way to think about things here's a fun
one we've talked about a whole bunch of
historical figures and development of
this right Copernicus Kepler Galileo
Newton they lived in very different
times we're talking 1500s 1600s did any
of these people when they were thinking
about their science their systems of
astronomy and physics
did they ever invoke God that's a good
question and the answer is you know yeah
sure of course
this was a time when you know no one in
the year 1600 went around advertising
that they were an atheist maybe there
weren't any atheist I'm talking about
Western Europe now with the history with
which I know just a tiny bit about
everyone professed to believe in God and
some people did so many people did so
extremely sincerely Copernicus I don't
know anything about his personal beliefs
but I know that Kepler was very
religious he thought of his whole system
of the celestial spheres and so forth
ellipses and Kepler's laws as
illustrating the precision and beauty of
God's system
Galileo I suspect Galileo couldn't care
less I'm not saying that he was an
atheist I honestly don't know maybe a
galileo scholar will chime in
I think the Galileo just never thought
about what God was supposed to do and
certainly wouldn't give God credit or
any responsibility in pushing things
around in the universe Newton is the
interesting case because on you know on
the one hand Newton invented classical
mechanics this beautiful system and I'm
mention that in some way classical
mechanics decreases the need for God
because you don't need something to be
pushing you don't need an unmoved mover
things just move by themselves that's
just what things do so this argument
from a first cause or a first mover that
was very popular back in those days it's
not the only argument for the existence
of God there's also the argument from
design right the argument from design
that the exquisite design of nature
nature is very elegant very beautiful
maybe even finely tuned for our
existence and to attribute that elegance
that simplicity and also just the law
like character of motions of things in
the universe to God that's an argument
for the existence of God why should
things obey the laws of physics at all
if God didn't make them do that
Newton totally bought that kind of
argument and he said about his own
system of classical mechanics
I mean basically God must exist to
invent something as beautiful as the
thing that I just invented but it went
beyond that a little bit you know
Kepler when he talks about the planets
going around the Sun he just invented he
imagined they were going these beautiful
pristine ellipses Newton went beyond
that as we discussed you know Newton
said well okay but there's more than one
planet and here's a planet moving here
in some trajectory here's another planet
moving here and some other trajectory
and I've just invented the law of
universal gravitation so I know that
these planets are not just going to be
pushed around by the Sun they will also
have the gravitational influence of each
other on them so they will not move
perfectly in ellipses and Newton I I
don't know whether he worked this out or
where they just intuited it but he kind
of had the feeling that if that were
true something as beautiful as the solar
system wouldn't last forever this turns
out to be correct it wasn't really
understood until maybe on Rippon Caray
circa the year 1900 but yeah the solar
system can be thought of as unstable if
things go wrong the planet can be just
you know launched out of the solar
system and it's happened in the past so
Newton didn't like that idea he thought
the solar system should be permanent so
he said very explicitly that he imagined
that God would occasionally in
to mean that God would come along change
the velocity of the planets line him
back up so everything was hunky-dory
once again there's no experimental
evidence for that by the Year 1800
pierre-simon Laplace was you know
pooh-poohing that idea he he probably
was just legitimately an atheist I don't
know exactly the details there either
but he certainly thought the idea of
using God relying on God to explain your
cosmology and astronomy was a bad idea
you know these days in case this was the
subtext of the question most scientists
are probably not themselves personally
religious but there are some were a
little bit religious there are some were
very religious very few scientists would
invoke God in their science right as an
explanatory feature of how they talk
about the world maybe they'll put it to
create the Big Bang or something like
that but again most of them most of us
don't really need God around anymore to
explain the natural world okay
back to physics are there any
experimental tests or could there be I
guess I wish I were better at talking
and writing at the same time are there
experimental tests of the discreteness
of time I talked about at the very end
of the last video the idea that all this
calculus stuff relied or presumed that
time was smooth the time was continuous
that there was a an infinite number of
moments of time infinitesimally close to
each other that's why we needed calculus
if it were if reality or more like a
computer maybe it is maybe you live in a
simulation or something like that but
computers tend to be digital they
approximate smooth curves by chunking
forward in discrete amounts it may be
although we don't know that the real
world is also like that the time truly
is discrete if that's true could we
experimentally test it well we certainly
hope so I mean we absolutely hope so we
don't know for sure but we're absolutely
trying so it's not enough to say well
maybe time is discrete what's the
experimental test you need a theory you
need to say here is how time works
and it is discrete you can test theories
you don't sort of test ideas okay so
there might be different ways for time
to be discrete and have different
experimental consequences I will I will
mention one place where it's natural to
look which is I think I mentioned it
maybe already or maybe it's just in my
head
Lorentz invariance Lorentz invariance
comes not from Isaac Newton but in
relativity the idea that how fast you're
moving through the universe doesn't
matter okay that if that's true how fast
you're moving in the universe doesn't
matter you know that from Einstein that
the rate at which clocks tick will
appear different to an observer that is
moving fast than an observer that is
moving slowly and if you can move at any
different velocity then you can make the
clock seem to be ticking at any
different amount and therefore doesn't
seem like times discrete so naively if
time is discrete there should be some
violations of Lorentz invariants
somewhere and these are things that are
being tested so we're looking for them
there's no evidence of it yet but we
absolutely would love to see either
evidence for it or evidence that really
put very strong constraints on it okay
two more questions about the future of
physics we're going to peer into the
speculation realm here a little bit our
Newton's laws so F equals MA and the
others are Newton's laws completely true
or are they just valid in some regime so
there's sort of two answers to this one
is no they're absolutely not completely
true because we know they're not
completely true we know there's quantum
mechanics we know there is relativity
and presumably we'll just get worse
right I mean presumably as we know more
and more about physics what we learn and
what we completely expect at least sorry
let me put it this way we probably
didn't expect this in the 1800s
but by the time the revolutions of
relativity in quantum mechanics came
along and we saw that Newtonian
classical physics and Newtonian gravity
were both limiting cases that
or approximations to relativity in
quantum mechanics the idea that we'll
have another theory in the future that
is even more comprehensive so that
relativity and/or quantum mechanics are
approximations to them valid in some
regime became very palatable so many of
us expect that something like that is
going to be true I wouldn't be at all
surprised if quantum mechanics is
exactly right in some sense but
relativity general relativity the idea
that space-time is curved etc is almost
certainly an approximation because the
classical theory we know the classical
mechanics is an approximation to quantum
mechanics so in that kind of trivial
sense we know that Newton's laws are not
completely true but let's imagine that
we are in the regime where Newton's laws
are supposed to be true are they still
completely true there so we're not
moving the speed of light or close to it
where big macroscopic objects no quantum
effects are really evident there's still
a sense in which Newton's laws might
appear not to be true when a ball rolls
down a hill it eventually comes to a
stop right because of friction so in the
real world we are constantly using some
version of Newton's laws in ways that
are only sort of halfway applicable so
they're not supposed to be the complete
description we can we can set up we can
talk about a theory of something that is
part of the world but not the whole
world Newton's laws have no trouble
talking about a ball rolling down a hill
but you can derive conservation of
momentum from Newton's laws how do you
reconcile that well you say the
application of F equals MA to the ball
rolling down a hill was true but the
kinds of forces there cannot be
themselves derived from Newton's laws
you're making some extra assumptions so
there's this sort of more immediately
relevant sense in which Newton's laws
are completely true only if you're
really being comprehensive only if
you're really getting down to the
nitty-gritty of all the atoms and
molecules and applying them exactly
which in many appropriate cases we just
don't want to do so even in the
classical world even in the world of
18th century physics or 19th century
physics there were there was a sense in
which Newton's laws weren't
true but we thought that's just cuz we
weren't doing the full job that we might
want to do okay final question are the
laws of physics themselves laws of
physics changing so we talked about
change in the sense of an object
changing its position or its velocity
over time or its acceleration or
whatever so but we took the laws did I
break that correctly I'm not sure I did
we took the laws themselves to be fixed
so these days in cosmology and particle
physics in string theory or whatever is
very very common to at least imagine
that the laws are changing that
somewhere else in the universe or some
other moment of time the charge of the
electron was a little bit different or
the mass of the electron in fact
essentially all modern working particle
physicists think that in that sense the
laws of physics did change
remember we discovered the Higgs boson
back in 2012 the Higgs boson gave gives
mass the Higgs field that pervades all
space gives mass to the electron because
the Higgs value the Higgs field has a
value in empty space the picture that we
typically draw here is here's the energy
of the Higgs we'll call it the potential
as a function of the value of the Higgs
field here's the Higgs field and it
looks kind of like this okay so if the
Higgs field were zero it would have a
lot of energy wrapped up in it but if
the Higgs field falls down to this value
the value of the Higgs field is non zero
but the energy is and we think that's
where we are and this breaks a symmetry
it could have rolled to the right or to
the left and so that's why we have
spontaneous symmetry breaking in physics
but it turns out that in the early
universe when you're not empty space all
around you but in fact there's a plasma
of ultra hot gas and particles bumping
into you all the time this what we call
this potential energy for the Higgs
field changes it looks like this
in other words at high temperature the
Higgs field is at zero that's where it
sits at the bottom of this kind of curve
not the bottom of this double weld
potential and what that means is that in
the early universe the mass of the
electron was a different thing so if by
the laws of physics you mean what
physicists call the low energy laws of
physics the laws of physics that have to
do with the particles and forces that we
see in the universe around us yes those
do change we expect that they might
change even more dramatically elsewhere
but we think that they do change but
it's kind of like you know does the what
I say does the speed of sound in water
change well yeah the speed of sound is
different in ice versus liquid water
versus water vapor okay but we don't
think that's a profound fact about the
universe we think that there is some
essence of water and is underlying the
whole thing I think that most of us
think the same thing here and this is
just thoughts this is not anything we
have strong evidence for so maybe we're
all wrong but I think that we most
physicists think that even if the laws
of physics that we observe what we call
the low energy effective laws are
different from place to place or time to
time there are still deeper laws meta
laws if you want to call them that but
even deeper more fundamental laws that
don't change over time that the specific
particles and forces we see are
manifestations of a particular set of
arrangement of stuff that still obeys
the meta laws of quantum mechanics and
whatever it is string theory whatever it
turns out to be ultimately but like I
said we don't know this is ultimately an
experimental question you'll be happy to
learn if you don't already know this is
another thing that we are absolutely
trying to test experimentally we're
looking to see whether or not the
electron has a different mass now than
it did in the past I've written papers
about this myself
so this is an example of a very good
question this is the kind of thing we
should be thinking about
I hope these videos are helping us all
to think about these big questions as
time goes forward